yesterday a bunch of leaders from the
crypto industry went in front of
congress and they got asked all kinds of
questions there's a couple of different
people who were there so first we got
the circle ceo jeremy o'leary was there
ftx ceo sam bankman freed was there
bitfury ceo brian brooks was there paxo
ceo chad cascarilla was there uh the
stellar development foundation ceo
danella dixon was there and the coinbase
cfo alicia haas was there as well uh
these six people went in front i think
most people were just like this is going
to be absurd nobody knows anything if
you remember we said that you should
literally have to take a quiz before
you're allowed to ask questions but i
was pleasantly surprised there was
actually pretty solid questions there's
a lot of people who are trying to
understand what is going on in the
industry how do these leaders understand
or think about where the world is going
now of course there were people who
understood it there were plenty of folks
who were trying to actually be
productive but if
as in any situation there's always that
one person that one smartass that one
person who's got to troll who's got to
be the idiot in the room
so of course i'm going to play the video
because
i don't want you to think that i'm
making this stuff up here is a video of
i believe this brad sherman just
judge it for yourself
now
the number one threat to crypto
currency is crypto
bitcoin could be depl displaced by ether
which could be first place by dodge
which should be placed by a hamster coin
and then there's cobra coin and what
could [ __ ] coin do to crypto coin
what
hamster coin
and mongoose coin he called it dodge
like the car
like
i
in the past if you're new here to this
industry brad sherman has been saying
ridiculous things for years about the
industry and so a couple of years ago i
went and i looked and i said why would
brad sherman the guy who frankly nobody
really knows outside of uh people who
pay attention to like congress why would
he be so anti-innovation be so
anti-bitcoin or cryptocurrencies well
one of the best examples is guess who
brad sherman's donors are majority of
the largest ones are payment processors
or credit card processing firms it's
literally the competition
so when you all of a sudden look at
somebody like a brad sherman and you say
he's funded by somebody who's going to
be disrupted by this technology
of course he doesn't like it
but he was the outlier yesterday years
ago he would have been the standard the
default everyone would have been acting
the way that he does but instead
yesterday i was very pleasantly
surprised because most of the questions
were actually very very
informative and also in good faith from
what we could tell the standout i think
for in most people's mind was brian
brooks they hadn't heard really heard
him talk a lot and he did a fantastic
job of explaining a lot of the industry
but also calling out in a very
politically correct way issues that he
sees with regulation and so when you
look at these folks circle ftx bitfury
paxos and coinbase i think most people
say that makes a lot of sense there was
number five there i was a little
confused why stellar development
foundation was there but i tend to think
that ultimately this was a net positive
for the entire industry because this was
the first time that i think it became
obvious that there are good faith actors
on both sides and when they come
together and they talk about this stuff
there is a potential solution on the
horizon joe and john what do you guys
think about uh this performance by folks
who in front of congress yesterday well
my first thought was brian armstrong
busy
yes yes i'm sure he was uh my second is
it's not surprising and it's funny that
you say that he's backed by a bunch of
credit card processors and stuff like
that because that was my first thought
when i saw the clip was he's obviously
got some kind of uh acts to grind
against this but it's not surprising i
think we've seen over time that some
politicians are just gonna be willfully
ignorant to this stuff uh no matter kind
of how much you try to educate them so
whatever wash them to the side try to
educate other people who are open-minded
and we'll look at this from a good uh
lens or a good frame of mind but no it
wasn't really that surprising to see
someone like him say something like that
john
that was a tough video to watch
that was a little ridiculous but i also
think that this whole meeting was about
regulation in the industry sec has
obviously talked about it being a
security for a long time um and kind of
their thoughts around that but congress
doesn't really have much kind of input
on here i appreciate all the executives
of the cryptos company going there and
actually showing face and answering
their questions and trying to educate
them on the industry but while they're
all focused on regulation tens of mil
tens of millions of people have flooded
money tens of millions of americans have
flooded money into the crypto market and
are kind of deciding for themselves so
we're gonna see where that is he talked
about the biggest threat to
crypto the biggest threat to the united
states dollar is the united states
dollar what do you think is one of the
biggest threats to bitcoin and
cryptocurrency in general
time
that's it it's biggest one
time the the more time we have the more
likely it is to succeed the less time
that we have if you're looking at a one
or five you know a one month one year
time frame that's the biggest things we
run it we don't have enough time but the
more time that goes by the more adoption
we get
we have three other quotes from folks
that were out there at the hearing
yesterday patrick mchenry a u.s rep from
north carolina he said we need
reasonable rules of the road we know
that we don't need knee-jerk reactions
by lawmakers to regulate out of fear of
the unknown rather than seeking to
understand and that fear of the unknown
in the move to regulate before
understanding will only stifle american
ingenuity and put us at a competitive
disadvantage
patrick henry you get it then we have a
quote from jeremy elaire from circle ceo
this is an open financial system crypto
creates an opportunity for anyone with a
mobile device anywhere in the world to
seamlessly exchange value with one
another jeremy you get it and then we've
got roger
williams the u.s congressman who said
all of you were working tirelessly to
create something new in order to bring
this new technology to the masses
unfortunately would only take a few
misguided curveballs we'll say from
washington to undo some of this progress
roger you get it as well
i i really felt like yesterday was the
first time i was like oh my god the
politicians are going to get orange
peeled they're going to get red pilled
here like they are all going to go in on
this because i think they see the
writing on the wall and it's like if you
are short whether through regulation uh
sentiment uh financially uh whatever
this industry you're basically long wall
street and the only thing
that politicians hate more
than bitcoin or crypto is wall street so
it's like you know the enemy of my enemy
is my friend well you would think
politicians
and the crypto community doing this
right now right and why doesn't
elizabeth warren get it right like she's
been a bigger she gets it does she
though i mean she should because this is
because to be fair bitcoin is exactly
what she's been arguing for i just don't
think she understands that for the last
decade right or last two decades
everything that she said about wall
street a lot of those problems are
solved by the bitcoin ecosystem and the
bitcoin network and people transferring
their assets into that i think what she
doesn't get is she hasn't put in the
time in the effort to understand what it
actually is
elizabeth warren funds wall street
most people think of it the opposite way
that wall street funds you know how she
pays fees to wall street banks she's a
bank right
if you really believe that they're so
evil then stop using the banks
right
like i don't want to hear what you say
show me your actions do you use a bank
okay then obviously we need banks now
you can argue that maybe they need to be
better but if you believe so deeply in
what you're doing then stop using the
banks but it's just like wha like what
are you trying to accomplish for the
last two decades then right about
arguing
if someone presents a solution to you
and then you're close-minded and you
don't accept that solution like you're
obviously not trying to progress
anything it's just a bunch of air
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
uh operators entrepreneurs investors etc
have been building solutions while
politicians have been complaining about
the problem and now it is not the job of
a politician to build the solution
especially technology solutions etc but
when they are presented to your point a
solution and they don't go ahead and
take the time to learn about it they
instead just say oh you're just as bad
as these people
listen we've got one system that's a
closed system that's completely opaque
that no one understands really in depth
has incredible risks and there's high
hierarchical centralized control of and
then we have another system that's fully
digital fully transparent that's
decentralized that no one person or
group controls
you tell me which system's better and
guess what the people are choosing
they're literally voting with their feet
they're voting with their wallets
they're moving to the new system and
most young people i mean i would argue i
don't speak for you two
majority of my economic value that is
tied to my name is not in a bank it is
in this new system and so i think most
young people or a large portion of young
people that's happening and so they're
voting with their dollars they're voting
with their wallet they're saying hey you
guys suck i'm gonna go here this is a
superior system and politicians should
get on board or get left behind